there we go we got a nice Star Wars
reference did you watch Star Wars Hikaru
yeah yeah well not not the not the
travesty that is the Disney ones but the
other ones yes there were they the Oh
G's the O G's okay we got liftoff and
he's playing efore we expected a
Sicilian Knight of three and we expected
this as well I told him to play d4 Oh No
why why is he hesitated okay we were
about to see h4 and I was about to rage
quit that's good and and here I
predicted she'll play east six but we
also looked at C takes d4 and she played
neither okay
well that's that's as far as the
preparation is going to go
coach botas back at it again predictions
all the way to move three
[Laughter]
good coaching
thanks Hikaru okay I will say I didn't
expect this because it's a bad move I
told him if she makes a bad move push
the pause so let's see if he sees d5
nope
this is okay as well although she's okay
as well I wonder who prepared her with
b6
any insight there Hikaru inside-out into
what who prepared her with this b6 line
I well like I said I didn't I didn't do
any preparation so if anyone gets her it
would be Chi Yu but I think she just
forgot to move borders is I think my
best guess all right well let's take a
listen on Ludwig and see what he has to
say here any sense oh oh no what pawn
takes pawn
oh no okay
they're both missing the pawns here I
did think she would take on I hope he
protects it with a bishop nope
this is fine okay so no now you just
take the pawn of course on d4 yeah every
single facet of the Sicilian and what
choko would do and I will say choko has
done everything as alex predicted and I
still go no I did I'm doing she I
predicted and now we're down to pawn
Ludwig
well I doesn't feel good I miss them
three I think I think everyone has at a
moment like this in the event there were
someone that they helped has has done
something that just makes them want to
rip their hair out so you're not the
only one I think everyone everyone has
had this happen oh I forgot to do g5
that was the move not casting what it
was another line my head feels like
Bishop hey it still went better than
your preparation with him when he mixed
it up with he 5 and f 5 okay right no no
I was laughing at his remark about
corrugated cardboard but so position
actually is completely fine for white
anyway okay so does this now she should
play oh but this is a very good moves
there's 9701 wig oh he's got he five and
I showed him he five he better play it
we talked about this we talked about
this he's seen this trap he's seen this
trap come on Ludwig also ninety-six
verse is also fine I'll be happy with
either this seems fun this seems really
fun let's do this your Castle okay so
now I'm king of 85 again still is
winning yeah he still has a move after
okay I mean also it turned out pretty
good it turned out pretty good cuz we
did discuss 96 ideas Bishop g5 ideas and
e5 so it seems like he's gonna combine
you have to move one night checks King
unless you can take Knight there's no
way to interpose
[Music]
I guess the question is where do you
move
god I'm so nervous I want to hear him
think about what he's gonna do Sounders
Shamu sir King think on her time Ludwig
is low don't try and look like Steve
Jobs or something oh that's a good one
okay now e5 is begging to be played it
really is it really is do you think
she'll fall for it no come on let away I
was gonna go here then hope she takes
and then I go here but then she could
also just take my night with her a night
and I don't think she'll miss that you
touch the pawn you touch the pawn for a
second more clever I could do not really
I think it's harder to watch the people
you coached oh that's definitely true I
think I think I think in general
especially the people who I feel like
we've had to help more especially some
of the people in consolation bracket
like you really want to see them succeed
you really want to see some of these
some of these plans play out and then
when it doesn't it can be very back for
sure so so I totally I told it grew that
especially since I've watched XQ sees
games in particular oh yeah I don't
think I was a necessary move at all I
mean I'm still better because there but
now she can fix her position I'm on to
h6 there you can remove this Bishop on
g5 okay so we're not gonna go for the e5
move um but he'll he'll push the bishop
back which is still good and and I will
say charcoal bars is defending very well
I think she needs to get full credit
there right so she plays d5 which I like
okay no Knight Knight to e5 which also
hits the pawn hit hits night on messy
game this is I don't think I've even
considered it yeah and then he can bring
his knight into the center if she finds
the psuedo castling plan mm-hmm yeah I
think I mean I think what work is doing
is doing doing doing quite well but
again it depends on what the next next
sequence of moves are for both sides
right right okay so there should be
seven which is not the best move because
now you can take the knight I mean the
main thing as a black needs to push the
bishop off of this diagonal this is this
is very critical right and he can still
go for the knight c6 Bishop takes an e5
idea because even if she plays g5 to
attack the bishop then we take the
knight with check it's just a bit of a
hard sequence to see but he might see
the moves one at a time right I think he
sees moves one at a time is fine I think
it's very important that he does not
take this pawn okay no no no we're
supposed to go to e5 not
to d5 now if chocolate bars takes
tonight and plays Queen takes pawn
what would might run the risk of getting
checkmated oh that's not a good but she
now opened up the the e-file for him as
well well the funny thing is there is no
clear-cut checkmate though there's no
like no way to win material so after
Ricky won as long as you move the king
off of this open file while white is
better there's no clear-cut way to win
the game
okay so what she should do is King f8 do
you think that's a hard move to find or
is that a reactive move because the rook
is on the same file I think it should be
a reactive move here I think you just
have to look down the board and see see
the your King is under attacker
oh no she's gonna play g5 isn't she oh
and then we get to take on c6 with h3
quickly double-check well if we see it I
mean there's a world where he plays
Bishop g3 I'm not going to get ahead of
myself
okay and let's take a look at chocolate
bars see what she's planning but I will
eat him if he tries I need to get my
very nice job I thought her hovering
over the pond going g5 there no yeah
yeah that would have been a scary scary
move to see maybe I just trade these off
so I don't have to think about it I mean
there'll still be a horse here but
knowing that horse is probably my
weakest I probably need to like chill
out a bit on that I think this is
actually a hard position for white to
continue playing accurately here and
hold the advantage I mean obviously for
us it would be quite three or four you
take the knight and take the pawn but I
feel very natural I don't think you're
any and again there aren't really many
open lines here can I move my horse here
instead then no I think I just take that
it's it's an even trade I mean nothing
it's he just stays here I just really
want so he's threatening my horse I
think we just take the trade I mean I'm
really scared I'm making a mistake now
though take the trade if this is this
and I do this then there's there's a
horse here is that bad this is watching
this so the Queen can never just eat
this pawn
yeah I didn't like mission b5 but it
does feel like a natural move just go
for it because it creates stuff right
mm-hmm right I need to find a way this
one two one two okay so this looks like
an is it even though I'm scared to take
this but I think it's okay I can't think
to belong I don't know what the right
answer is uh-oh this is risky cuz her
knight on c6 is hanging now for some
reason she didn't realize that the
bishop and the knight are both attacking
you saw her thinking that it was just a
bishop and the bishop okay I mean all
right yeah he just played Bishop d3
instead of taking the night but this is
also fine Wow okay it's not as so now I
mean now it's now it's important that
she sees the knight is under attack it's
absolutely imperative here to basically
just trade the knights if I go again
here I think more players are filling
more opportunities for my bishop and the
only thing my knight was watching
earlier was this and this is fine
because I have this so now I look at
this so now if I take this it's even or
it's it's not so bad well link is going
to see the night because that's why he
played Bishop e5 him stopping me from
what did I do wrong I know I didn't do
anything wrong yeah now this is looking
pretty
and so the blundering begins that was a
little little tough to see on choco bars
end okay you're right he did see one of
the nights he can even put his knight
back in the center he just needs to be
careful now because his knight is the
one under attack actually I mean putting
a knight on e5 is so strong right now
because there's an extra pin right
exactly yeah so that would be a big good
move here alright well let's let's take
a listen on Ludwig as Walden
there's that video game music
very focused we actually haven't talked
about the clock situation yet Ludwig's
have five minutes she's at four they've
both been pretty pretty decent with time
management so far right exactly yeah I
think I mean I think blood was
definitely in the driver's seat but he
has to find he has to find some good
moves here
in the next couple moves although he is
starting to get a big advantage on the
clock at this point right and it seems
like I mean they've both both missed a
few tactics but chaco has mix missed the
biggest tactics so far and we also saw
that when she was in time pressure
queens eager to join kick-ass blunder I
can take advantage of oh well no I guess
that's right Knight takes c6 hold up
let's think about this think about this
we have a discovered move how can take
advantage move here doesn't work here
doesn't work here doesn't work
missing Knight takes c6 yeah I just take
this for free down
the queen is the weakest move or the
weakest piece on the board every single
time it's under threat you have to move
I studied English in high school or
sorry college um yeah go anywhere in
this I don't know actually it's possible
though certainly it's possible something
yeah I could see that because of his his
vocabulary it's very impressive from
having watched Ludwig for mm-hmm few
weeks now all right well now he's up so
he know apparently he was action English
major like he was actually ya know III
think he actually had mentioned it
before as well I wasn't I wasn't trying
to do a a I mean nevermind let's - if I
go here then she takes me I can take her
free
that's fine cuz then I get a rope yeah
that sounds fine
applies more pressure on to the Queen so
she'll have to move the Queen not many
squares no no no no no yeah that makes
sense that's what I figured would happen
now I take with my bishop I'm digging
the tunes honestly she also you seem to
be a big fan of this that's for sure I
coached I'm always a fan of the people I
coach Hikaru Wow
I'm never complimenting anyone that's
really unfair every time I compliment
someone people assume that I'm just big
fans of all the streamers
no no but anyway joking aside Ludwig
obviously he is he screwed on me to kind
of speak to be fair like the jokes the
memes everything he brings the table
it's it's pretty it's it's it seems like
you're quite karo I think you're right
happy Pride Month everybody that's true
actually it is Pride Month yeah uh-huh
yep well as if you were unfamiliar yeah
okay all right
anyway though wait wait what just
happened it he just wait he's hung the
night wait which has happened while we
were having our fun oh there's still
Queen before that looks like it's almost
right mm-hmm
yeah I guess I mean if he sees it it was
quite brilliant but I suspect that he
just blundered the night maybe me yeah
oh you're right
you're right but he's so close to check
meeting I mean the king is almost gonna
be forced back on the ei if he sees it
right right exactly yeah but she's not
but he's still okay Queen before now is
begging Oh
all right now that one's reading I mean
I guess what I would say also to be fair
to all the players is that I think
they're certainly feeling some pressure
for sure
I like in the group stage I think they
were much more relaxed but now that it's
in this stage were I mean it's
elimination basically I think all the
players are feeling much more nervous
so now Richie six here would be a great
move by black now whether whether
chocolate bars can find that or not I'm
not sure but it would be uh it would be
a very very nice move right because she
means wow she's making space for her
King
that's super impressive very nice move
by chocolate bars yeah and I think I
mean really again as with the previous
games while uh while Ludwig's up a piece
he has to be very mindful at the clock
again because he's only up one minute
and if this gets back to even time I
think I think generally what I would say
is the caught up is that both players
have say two minutes or thereabouts or
under the position is it is relevant but
if it's within like one rook or one
Bishop anything can happen tonight sees
Queen before check but it's one move to
lakes now you go King g8 right and yeah
he played h3 too quickly he played it in
two seconds I think if he would have
thought a little longer he may have seen
this but chocolate bars should feel
really proud that she made space for her
Queen now um Queen c5 is no Bishop e6 is
a from a blender but he he can just
trade and be in a better endgame here
right and now I mean now I think he
should convert this pretty cleanly he's
up one bishop okay she sees rookie six
though which is not a bad move now with
Ludwig see Bishop d6 check or not is
another question okay so now f6 here I
think the dance starts to go away so if
you push the pawn to f6 which is not an
easy move to see but if you push the
pawn to f6 I think it's game on again
and oh she sees it oh wow okay Wow okay
now I know I don't know what's gonna
happen
yeah now she's gonna win the piece back
and okay she'll win the piece back and
he's still up to pawns but almost
anybody's game if he thinks too long but
yeah hikaru diva wretzky Zend Emmanuel
okay so now if you take the take the
rook of course
okay so and it's pretty obvious here
because you have two pieces lined up so
I'm pretty pretty confident that she'll
take take the brook and take the bishop
it's the only try here but it's
important to make moves quickly as well
like you can't really be using time this
at this moment all right well we are
gonna take another listen on little
extreme
okay he's very focused I think he
notices I mean he must know that he was
wandering to pieces but he's he's trying
to be careful not giving away any more
funds I think hungry is a good move
yeah a 3pt career good move I think it's
important the black tries to attack
responses in writing anything can happen
okay and I like that she's going and
just the foggy and provoking all of his
pawns
she's also putting great Boise's okay
now yes sir he's giving a check so if he
sees rooks e7 and taking the pawn that
would be good yeah I think he sees that
thing he's probably gonna win the game
and he's even the time advantage go down
forty on one thing I would take he was I
think he played a lot of the slingshot
he played a lot of the cooker game so I
think thank you Doug Ford ski this was
for you
te kuru said I could spend a life and
not understand two pages are you seeing
this Hikaru I understand every word
[Laughter]
literally till I give this whole thing
prepares prepare now you have to go King
c7 to stop the pawn of course only move
as king c7 right and if she does see
that then it's actually kind of in
trouble again you can't push it okay
[Music]
that's forward too so it seemed like she
was getting out of the position and her
King was back on f8 it was looking more
safe let me played Bishop b5 which
wasn't the correct move because it's
almost feeding his opponent into playing
the correct move which is Knight takes
e5 unfortunately she played g5 first and
then blundered her night on g5 right
yeah Knight g4 I think was a critical
critical blunder there is more important
to trade the Knights and go 94 but
anyway blood what Ludwick played well he
definitely was a deserving winner of
that first game only really the one
mistake was giving back that Bishop but
otherwise can't really fault his moves
he missed some wins earlier but but he
didn't really make any serious mistakes
right and I'm just gonna bring bring the
point where he gave his Bishop away here
and he didn't miss a couple
opportunities with with Queen before
check but I think he saw that he was up
a bishop and he needed to go for
simplification which you know with his
endgame skills that he just showed off
seems like a sound strategy right so I
thought I thought for the most part very
very good game by Ludwig one thing I
noticed is he's very good in it and that
maybe not a nice but simpler positions
were like they're they're very simple
ideas he tends to find them without too
much difficulty so very very impressive
bye-bye Lud win the first game but there
is a second game still to be played so
again um all these players when they
lose the first one they still have a
chance to come back and win in the
second game right and we will be
starting that game soon chocolate bars
is going to get the white pieces which
tends to be quite favored in the
pogchamp schemes that we've seen so far
right mm-hmm all right
um so she's going for Knight of three
and and the setup we looked at it was
something like d5 Knight of six knight
c6 e v just trying to go for the center
here because I got a game choco bars
played against you this variation
so let's take a listen on chocolate bars
and see how she's recovering after that
loss ok nothing yet
she's focused she doesn't seem too
rattled
this is good oh I spoke too soon you are
a fivehead yourself think about all the
puzzles you did am i all your lessons
trade trade a trade a tree today waiting
for a minute it's not there I just need
to trade it down ok not what we
discussed
that's a move ok alright this is totally
different I'm so glad we had that lesson
really a good use of my time
that's fine he's gonna he's gonna
transpose he was gonna transpose well he
already gave her one minute on the clock
so so so far I think this is he's giving
odds he's giving one minute I monster at
the start
mm-hmm oh I feel like chocolate Wars is
actually nervous um she and the pep talk
after the loss is nice she's she's
trying to build herself up and she
should because it does feel bad to just
lose the game and go straight into the
next one mm-hmm oh he's going for the
trade okay okay this I don't like at the
start I I think it's uh unnecessary yeah
I was actually trying to explain when we
did our lesson ideas with like Bishop e6
and Queen d7 instead he went for the
trade you know a little deviation there
but that's okay so
I guess the good thing for him is that
if he even gets in Tennant we're not
gonna see a lot of draws but he does
have draw odds just in case right right
this is also true yes definitely since
he has draw this is to his advantage but
again the one thing I would say is since
the position is simpler they're really
the pawn structure where the pawns are
it's less likely that you're gonna see
major mistakes you're by either side
mm-hmm okay before who that's a good
move
so now I have to go Knight 83 to protect
it well she see Knight 83 or not I don't
know it's important not to push the pawn
I think she will see it because I see
that she sees the threat of c2 and
there's no other option yes you're right
c3 does seem a little tempting
but would be a big mistake a3 is
actually kind of tricky though yeah III
is a pretty good move here as well maybe
even the best movement position but kind
of hard to see because she'd have to
play rook a to after and then the
problem is that Ludwig is trapping his
knight right exactly yeah Wow okay she
plays it I don't know if it's because
she saw it or because it just is
intuitive to try to kick the night out
okay he takes it which is actually not a
good move right so now after rook a to
his Knight is getting trapped all right
and we are going to take a listen on
Ludwig what do I want to do you know
what do I want to do with my life I say
you're going funny life why are you why
is he doing this now I guessed which
bronze make it better
I feel like I could consider castling
[Music]
yeah sure why not
I'm down
and now be for an love would that make
sense I guess please night see-through
which is also a good yeah she's she's
playing this really well actually this
is super impressive a 3r okay - I think
got smarter she can just play b3 and
attack oh oh no that's a free rook Oh
thousand-year bun oh oh oh
yeah I mean v3 was about to win the
night I'm taking that Bishop I'm taking
that bishop oh you don't move that
Bishop I'm gonna take him yeah that was
that was really rough honestly I think
she she just played too quickly
actually
now that you know what I almost did I
almost said hey trying to blunder all
right now I'll just take um yeah you
just trade now that's how you win please
take me please I like that he's just
going for the straight if you don't take
me my night will have been in a very bad
move it is very important I feel really
embarrassed if you didn't tie the trade
down when he's up by it when he's up by
one girl this is probably like the most
dog spot for a night
oh now the pawn on e3 was also hanging
but he already had his eye on the night
look at the wall holy
this wall is immaculate let's do this
let's avoid a back rank early early and
often you don't want a back rank in this
game I think well he has been playing
for a lot longer than choco bars so I do
think this is kind of fair for him to
see the tactics more often than yes yeah
I mean I think it's just unfortunate not
not really seeing the straight forward
ideas perhaps although b3 at beat the
idea beat her before was not very
obvious thing this side to side moves
I've noticed some not just her but some
of the other League guys like yeah so in
particular had trouble
noticing the side-to-side was like a
queen on a5 attacking like say something
on h5 and and the same thing apply
applying to other someone else that had
this issue I think it was hugely
actually we're like she just had trouble
seeing the side to side so just this
failure to see the side to side ideas uh
certainly um makes makes it makes it
difficult right and here he's about to
trade off another piece the bishop on c1
he can bring the rook to d3 when the e3
pawn she just has to be careful how
could he blunder here I mean like even
if he moves work that's actually a very
good move
so he's pinning the bishop right exactly
yeah well I mean for three weeks of
progress I'm still super impressed with
how far chocolate bars has come yeah for
unfortunately I think she's just playing
someone with a little bit too much
experience mm-hmm so yeah it's just
pretty unfortunate right
so rook takes c3 and he's just gonna
collect all of her pawns here right yeah
unfortunately it's just just winning
yeah he could offer her draw you know a
nice like oh he's pre moving is he just
pre moving okay don't pre-move g1 you're
gonna give your paw know it oh nice nice
pre moving there are you really
impressed with that sequence garbage
yeah I mean it's it's completely winning
no matter what happens um so so yeah
just just what just I mean I don't know
on the match what would divert etske say
about that pre move sequence
I think we're all right so we have
another result Ludwig beat choco bars to
zero you know if we go back to that
critical moment there before she
blundered we actually saw a very nice
continuation from chocolate bars I'm
just gonna bring that up before we get
on with the interviews so right mm-hmm
Ludwig was attacking c2 and she played
a3 kicking the night out Knight takes c2
and rookie - she found this nice escape
square for her hook the only issue is
that after a little bit castled if she
would have pushed before or b3 either
way I mean one is more direct cuz it
attacks of other bishop and the night
there's no square Ludwig can move his
knight so actually literally was gonna
be down an entire piece but instead she
played Knight c3 and then rook e1 just
wandering a full piece right exactly
yeah so I mean very tough unfortunately
when she blended rook e1 whereas B
through would have been winning the game
again I think what would go just a
little bit more experience and a better
grasp with the ideas right well chat
will be back soon
with player interviews and short break
until then and we are joined by Ludwig
and Janet from ex choco bars first let
me start off literally congratulations
for your win but you're going to be
making it on to the semi-finals Janet I
felt like you were playing strong chess
and then you just had a couple blunders
that that put you in a tough situation
hate the night please nerf it just take
it out of the game honestly I really
don't like that piece
it's my weakest link because I spend
like ten minutes
drawing out the arrows where it's gonna
go and stuff and I hate it I just hate
it I mean you've been playing chess for
less time than Ludwig so it does make
sense that it's gonna take you a little
bit longer to see these kinds of threats
so I still think you're an incredibly
fast learner and actually do you see the
position we have pulled up on zoom here
mm-hmm
so instead of playing rookie one you
actually had a winning move here if you
would have pushed b4 to attack Ludwig's
bishop you would have also attacked the
night at the same time so we were really
impressed with your a3 and rook b2 idea
thanks I appreciate that but I did I did
I do that you play an h3 and rogue a -
sorry but you you didn't claim before
this was right before you blundered your
work by playing with you oh yeah because
I saw him move it and I was tunneling
into that position that I wanted to take
in the middle and then he ate it and it
all fell apart after that's that's fair
and a lot of week how did you feel your
opening preparation when Alex I'll be
honest
ah you showed me every single opening
that would happen and and a different
variation happened so it just felt like
I had to think of every single move on
the spot and who's stressful it was a
stressful okay I mean you know there
were a couple ideas we discussed that
you just didn't put out on the board and
I have the vod's so just saying pods are
sub only so only like 30 people can see
it well so it did seem like your tactics
were really paying off here I think
that's probably why you won the games
you were really confident can you tell
us more about that you you pre moves
everything in the end here's the thing
here's the thing I was watching you guys
earlier commentate and you guys can't
comprehend our minds all right my my
Janet's mine slickers mind whoever's
mine because earlier on you remember
when Swift or had the Bishop to take
Queen mm-hmm I saw the same blunder I
was like I bet he's gonna blunder here I
don't look for good moves I understand
that most of the moves I make her
mistakes I look for the blunders because
they're gonna happen I've never played a
game ever in my life this is real ever
where there hasn't been at least one
blunder so I know it's gonna come I'm
just waiting for it and I'm baiting it
out unless I paint my blunder he did my
wonder he really did like I felt like it
was intentional like it was there
indubitably he car do you have any
comments you want to add related to
their game here no I mean I just I I
thought I mean love will you play you
played really quite well but in both the
games they're just much more experienced
on like in terms of Janna I mean it's
just tough luck but but certainly even
though you lost every game I think he
lost all five games you you definitely
played played better than that and and
you're just a little bit unfortunate in
terms of what happened once you were in
the once Ludwig why are you in this
bracket I don't understand what I I made
it to the consolation bracket because I
unfortunately lost a couple matches it
was unfortunate that
but a couple matches were lost there's
nothing we could have done about it
honestly I got outplayed by the players
that made me a lot of weight so up next
you're going to be going against the
winner from the xqc foosley match any
words for the Challenger you're gonna
get to take on I believe I don't have
this a leak I'm leaking if so I believe
I'm commentating it
do you guys you guys might not even know
this I believe I'm commentating them
somebody beat me and said do you know
anything about the t'car heard a rumor
about this yeah I believe I believe I'm
gonna be commentating it so I'm gonna be
an unbiased commentator I was one of the
premier commentators in super smash
brothers melee obviously did a lot of
top baits there and so they wanted my
expertise here so you know I'll come in
and I'll hey Karl I will show you the
world of blunders that you could never
imagine
mm-hmm for sure yeah looking forward to
it mm-hmm
that's gonna be amazing so this is going
to be happening tomorrow we're gonna
have a lot of ik n hikaru I'm gonna have
to tune in for that as well and Janet so
I know this is the end of the journey
for you but how has the pong champs
experienced been overall you know I do
think there were more positives than
negatives that happened throughout my
journey so that's fine I was hoping I
would go against similar talented people
like myself but it's like my first match
was forsen I mean come on okay but it's
Janet your accuracy was 73% mine was 74
percent all right look I do appreciate
the narrative that I'm a goddamn sebab
but in reality I'm just kind of dog the
game and people make excuses for me
because they think I'm better because I
had a good flash in the pan for a moment
I mean I think outside of that rug
blunder I was toast I was so nervous on
it can I say thank you
I was wedding and then you blundered it
made me feel like so much better myself
I'm sorry okay well you're welcome then
okay it's fine
I'm fine I got to meet you Alex and I
got to meet you Ludwick and I got to me
hikaru and I got coached by to you too
and everyone's just so kind
geom Hess was really kind nick is really
kind shadow to Gotham chess like
everyone's just so nice the experience
is great oh well thank you so much for
the kind words Janet we really
appreciate getting something nice from
one of the interviewees today in it for
the money Alex happy that I can put you
in the dirt can't wait to play xqc
amazing well thank you both for being
here and Ludwig looking forward to your
commentary tomorrow absolutely Absalon
biased by the way mm-hmm the commentary
it's gonna be with you no I meant good
luck in your next match or maybe maybe
you don't need luck you're you're just
not good all right we stuff that
transition probably my fault but here is
the championship bracket and the
consolation bracket sorry about that you
guys I was just you know a little taken
back by the fact that I'm getting my job
replaced by the one and only Ludwig
oh man Karl I feel bad I feel bad
mmm-hmm yes it's rough life is rough
sometimes well thank you for those words
of encouragement they they did
absolutely nothing to make me feel
better
life is rough thanks dad okay so
tomorrow we are gonna be seeing who's
Lee versus xqc thank you so much
everyone for being here this has been a
fantastic stream
I think it's been fun I mean I think
what I would say also is we had probably
saw probably the best match I think in
the entire event in that middle match
between forests in a box box certainly
the NA definitely the best match 1-1 tie
break so I think it's just it's great to
see that see all the players just
putting in their best effort and I mean
I think I think it's the best is yet to
come
all right chat well thanks so much
everyone for being here take care
everyone and we'll see you guys later
[Music]